[Music]
here don't go like this he comes up then
you race David's here then he's going to
aggress on me he just it I don't
put it on keep its position so you don't
have to go here then turn this you think
we're here he starts to move it so it's
already turned because I don't have to
do this weird
anything that's wouldn't be me now I'm
doing something it's not good way
[Music]
because right then I just wait he comes
in just here comes in
[Music]
her balance so when she's about to stand
up I go over here this is where I'm safe
and that's right for you then she
continues to get it she'll get up in the
law
balance condition here she comes
and I move myself to that heart go back
a little bit there you go
I don't move the arm to me I move myself
I'm going to move myself to the Lord
this is me moving the arms me me
quitting the law that's a no-no me me to
the law
she moves it on herself so go back she's
paid down no walk when she comes around
block but you have to be patient not be
afraid
Hey
okay don't confuse where I'm checking
okay so I'm not kidding here I'm just
I'm just touching okay right okay so the
same thing goes as I go around I come
here he comes into the law my hands is
touching him I'm not doing that that's
all sometimes I get lazy they're just
totally not care this is an instruction
then he gets up Eric never presses this
is an instruction okay harmonizing their
own
[Music]
sometimes this is John Young it's not
going to do with you
[Music]
how far do you take on but that's the
question
whoa hey if you have to bend his arm at
all to get it in position that was not
enough take on to where the arm does not
need to bet
and Concord is not okay so your little
top 10 funny it's not technique
[Music]
this is the same position here he comes
watch that so there's that energy okay
when when I deal I'm actually gonna let
it go by you see so not here I'm going
to be here
[Music]
it's basic Taoist concept if you've been
overridden don't get stronger try to
override less you're only been overrated
because you're trying to override so
it's very common if you're doing these
and you can't get this 5c well case
you're trying to make it go back instead
move there
okay here I am I go like this and I'm
turning his grip now I don't have to
technique so when you see that you're
losing the grip is because you're trying
to keep the grip don't don't keep the
grip okay I just hold it in here and
instead of using my hand and he goes I'm
using my bar you see that he goes and
not going and trying to turn that what
I'm doing instead is he moves keep it
there as if I was holding it it's like
keeping my body on the backside of it
you see this two different stuff I moved
to there he goes
and I move my body to keep it in place
as opposed to using my grip to make sure
it doesn't turn on I moved into place
where I can control his descent where
he's already falling okay so we're here
he gets up I'm moving a place where I
don't have to manipulate them now
then he starts to move and I move my
body
[Music]
here keep the law okay you're going to
not shove this down say the same thing
[Music]
in conjunction sweet you're applied with
so so there's a push okay if I yield you
should come in that's why I go round it
down
same thing here if he lays down
something else who can will feel go back
he's gonna feel the young but now it's
all you see that so he's gonna lift up
on it and instead of hammering down into
a young y'all I do the same thing I go
rumbling use that lift to take him into
the next I can stop that young reconcile
that y'all reconciled that he has gone I
saw young yes young